Yeah,
no,
we,
we really see our role as,
as a starting point for people when
they're looking for news.
Um,
our goal is really to try and help
people find the information they're
looking for yet in that way it's,
it's,
it's no different from what we're trying
to do with web search and it will show
headlines or snippets or sometimes just
the source named itself.
And then when people want to read that
story,
we send them directly after the
publisher's site.
So,
I mean,
in a given month,
just from Google news alone,
not even talking about Google,
the broader search index,
um,
we send about a billion clicks every
single month.
The publishers worldwide,
because I mean,
that's,
that's really consistent with what we're
trying to do.
We don't have content,
we don't have any editors and
journalists creating stories.
Uh,
we're just trying to surface that great
content that people are,
are,
are creating every single day,
whether it's traditional sources that
have been around for hundreds of years
or are new startups that are,
uh,
that are just fresh to the market.
Um,
and we have no intention of,
of,
you know,
pain simply for indexing a information,
but,
um,
I think sometimes there is a perception
that a,
it's an either or proposition that I can
put my content on the web and make it
freely available,
but if I decide to put up a paywall it
can't be,
I can't make it discoverable and that's
not the case.
And actually publishers who decided to
put up a paywall,
um,
can still be discovered within Google at
Wall Street Journal is actually a,
is a perfect example of that.
Um,
they've,
uh,
since they'd been on the web,
they've always had at least some set of
their content behind a paywall and
they've charged subscribers for that and
uh,
and that content has been available
within google news and also within
Google search as well.
So there are opportunities for
publishers if they decide that they feel
that they can charge for that content,
users are willing to pay for that,
they can do that and still decide that
they want to be discovered within
google.
So it's not a,
I don't think there,
there,
there are a number of different options
of how they can do so.
So it's not a,
I don't think it has to be an either or
proposition.
I think it would be a worse thing for,
for the end user if there are certain
searches,
return certain information and other
ones didn't.
Um,
but a publisher can decide how much
access they want to give for different
search engines and,
and do that fairly easily with just a
simple bit of code on their pages.
Right now.